la mine qui médiateur à sevran quand il
voit même ses images du policier qui se
fait lyncher la mine vous je sais vous
vous avez eu un on a tous vu vos images
1 c'était eux lors d'un contrôle
d'identité à sevran septembre 2019 vous
êtes vous avez été eux aussi été voilà
vous êtes battus et qu'un policier c'est
lui qui est venu vers vous je me suis
battu j'ai été agressé près ça c'est
vraiment plus s'il avait été agressé par
un policier vous à nous raconter
l'histoire va revoir les images mais
vous quand vous voyez des images mais
même si vous avez été agressé par un
policier comme vous dites on a tous vu
ces images
alors là là c'est quoi ça donc vous êtes
arrêté vous tasser un contrôle de police
même pas en fait faut savoir que c'est
le policier qui était mal garée ouais
d'accord il a commencé à se prendre la
tête avec un monsieur
ouais du coup nous nous sommes tous
sortis de nos voitures ouais
et comme moi je suis arrivé j'ai vu plus
gros est monté d'anciens foule il a dit
aux polices il a dit adieu monsieur si
tu me dis pas ça te plait se déplaçaient
en voiture maintenant dégage d'accord
moi j'arrive sur monsieur écoute toi
déplace ta voiture ça surtout avec lui
voulait ranger la faire exactement jeudi
des passes ta voiture ça sert à rien ne
va pas tu écoutais à ce moment là il se
retourne vers moi et me dit c'est quoi
ton problème toi je dis moi
personnellement je n'ai pas un problème
mais là tout le monde voit que le
problème c'est vous mais à part ça c'est
cool
il me dit je vais te contrôler je suis
d'accord y'a pas de soucis et c'est pour
ça qu'on voit ma voiture garée en plein
milieu de la route
je coupe le contact je pose toutes mes
affaires dessus je l'attends et pourquoi
il me dit qu'il va rencontrer jusque là
il dans son droit et dans son devoir est
donc là pas de soucis vous dites c'est
que si je veux montrer mes papiers donc
je l'attends et j'ai ma pièce d'identité
dans les mains on le voit quand les
petits jeunes et ramassent les affaires
et les a vraiment ma sacoche il a tout
et il vient il me dit en fait toi je
vais tendre mais je suis pardon dit moi
je vous dis expliquez moi pourquoi j'ai
pas commis de délit pas commis
d'infraction à quel moment vous allez
manger
il me dit je fais ce que je veux c'est
moins la loi donc là on le voit bien sur
la vidéo je tourne la tête j'ai dit aux
petits récupérer mes affaires
sur le capot de la voiture et là à ce
moment là et me saute dans les jambes
oui maintenant quand il saute dans les
jambes il a acquis un réflexe jeu se
déroule un jeune à trappes et quand je
la trappe
je lui parle je suis tu joue au con qui
sut fait l'art est we are enough
je relâche et quand je dors là j'arrive
les mains baissée vers lui
ouais les mecs qui veut rien savoir il
ment mais une queue j'esquive in
extremis bonbons ce cas là qu'est ce que
je fais je réponds je dormais et je
recule encore et je dis aujourd'hui
encore mais arretche teddy et de
soissons laon penche sur la vidéo il
veut rien savoir il me charge
on échange quelques coups à la fin je
frappe même plus je me laisse faire et
j'ai skié j'attends que à la fin vous
fait j'attends qu'ils me faisaient en
fait passer ça mais qu'est ce que j'ai
vu vous allez porter plainte j'ai porté
plainte
la plainte a été classée sans suite ah
ouais ouais voyage ça au tricot lahlimi
non agricoles et aux régions quand vous
expliquer sale affaire de la vigne parce
que s'ils réussissent à ces images
seront tournées partout tout en sachant
que excusez moi à légaliser la lutte et
pas les politiques ou l'asea vidéo qu'un
jeune homme a filmé de chez lui ouais
les gens qui étaient en bas avaient
filmé les policiers ont pris leur
téléphone effacer des vidéos là parce
que ce qu'ils disent
on sait pas ce qui s'est passé avant
mais si vos collègues n'avaient pas
effacé les vidéos des téléphones les
gens qui étaient dehors on se met sur la
consommation avec l'histoire de la
voiture du salon et est classé sans
suite elle vous l'avez recroiser
policière je les croisais une fois la
complémentation de l'agpm ouais il
travaille toujours
il a juste été muté il a dit quoi lui et
c'est quoi sa version lui sa version
c'est que quand il a su que j'avais la
vidéo il a prétendu notre âge soit
disant que j'avais dit [__]
ok d'accord quand bien même je t'avais
dit ça d'autres choses que je n'ai pas
dit d'accord ça mérite ce comportement